foreign
[Music]
not exactly safe you just need to keep
your eye out that's why I start packing
a little bit bigger gun
we really came out here just to follow
our dream of living this subsistence
life
that that was a brand new rookie out
here I'd be scared to death
it is great living but it's easy dying
out here as well all of our hands have a
little blood on it
with the Predators aren't out to get you
the weather is
okay you're going to want to watch out
are we going to build like a little
railing on the porch or anything it
could be I don't know about a railing
but I was thinking so the roof will hang
over right here we'll have two posts
coming up I like I like the idea this is
very much bigger than your average dog
house
I want the three bigger dogs to all be
able to fit in there together ladies
come here and provide a space to get out
of the rain out of the snow and out of
the elements should live on Olivia she's
having a pretty rough time getting
around with all those puppies sitting in
her tummy how many puppies do you girls
think she's gonna have
seven two hundred thousand hundred yeah
yeah too many all right Olivia's we
gotta get to work babe kids we're gonna
take the trees that we got we're going
to cut them to length and strip the bark
off of them with some draw knives
that doesn't have to be perfect you just
want enough off to where the moisture
will not stay in there and rot
want some help
you're saying no yeah
do you want to try guys
[Music]
can you scoop the log that way so I can
roll it
not this time around
to gain knowledge as a child of how to
do adult things that is so valuable like
all of these skills these are things
that typically aren't really taught in
school that part's kind of hard because
it's got knots in it here I'll turn it
and maybe try like this part okay I
think I got all the easy stuff and you
got all the hard stuff to do yeah pretty
good
oh you did oh okay
Lily is checking it out
foreign
[Music]
see where this one is right there I went
in from the side at an angle see how
solid that is that ain't moving
this is going to be fantastic
I like being away from people I like
being away from modern technology I like
to disconnect
create my own world
now live like people lived in the past
all right coming up to the snare line
first one right there easy enough it's
empty
my paycheck out here doesn't come in the
form of money it comes in the form of
meat and I need to find more meat
let me Center it a little bit more
all right keep on checking
you know it's interesting because I made
these paths with my snowshoes and now I
don't need snowshoes anymore because it
packs down and it freezes overnight and
the squishy hairs kind of do the same
thing they just go in the same exact
place so they're making little highways
I'm making little highways everything I
do out here I'm learning from the
animals
see what's happening here
nothing trap looks good no new tracks at
all around it
keep on checking
[Music]
[Music]